foreign
[Music]
all right here we go guys it is the
crystallia hour
um welcome to it you know what I mean I
got uh we got the pockets stay deep
merch up and running
absolutely wonderful and uh we've got
some life ripped decals I actually
forgot about these absolutely gorgeous
absolutely gorgeous and we've got the
grow or die merch so just gorgeous just
gorgeous and uh a bunch of different
merches go to crystalia.com I got some
life rip stuff uh we we preach but yeah
um and uh without further ado
welcome to the next episode of
congratulations
[Music]
hey yeah so that's uh you know we're
chilling
um we got Let's see we got dates coming
up
um we've got different uh dates coming
up we've got Irvine working on some new
stuff we've got Charlotte North Carolina
August 25th we've got Knoxville
Tennessee August 26th Little Rock
Arkansas September 7th uh Nashville
September 9th Calgary Alberta September
15th and we've got Edmonton and Ottawa
and Montreal and Hamilton and and in
Pittsburgh and Cleveland all right cool
so that's good
um get your tickets at christalia.com uh
I'm gonna go tell my son to stop banging
on the door
yeah can we
hey buddy
hey buddy hey buddy can we stop banging
please
thank you you can bang but but can you
just if you want to hit go out into the
other room where the TV is okay
thanks buddy love you
um
he's so cute dude the other day he was
uh we were driving by uh again it's a
weed store on Ventura Boulevard we were
going to get hot chocolate
for him uh you know me I don't drink hot
chocolate because I keep it lean right I
mean that's obvious at this point
uh but uh yeah your boy's getting swole
but yeah so we would drove by this weed
place and it had one of those wacky
inflatable Tube Man things I don't know
if that's what you're calling her if
that's what just Family Guy calls them
wacky inflatable two man wacky
inflatable two man but you know what I'm
talking about the things at the car lots
and they had it on top of this weed
store and it was a green one and he was
just doing his thing like
you know what I mean doing this thing
where it was the air was blowing into it
and then my son we were stopped in
traffic a little bit and my son just
says look at that
and I said whoa look at that buddy he
says what is that and I said oh that's
just one of those green things that's
that's that's filling with air and it's
like being like whacking it's an
inflatable tube and he took a beat and
he said
I'm that guy
and I said That's you and he said uh-huh
and I said oh oh okay
dude this was yesterday at
1 P.M
he's still that guy he's just going I'm
the wacky inflate I'm I'm inflatable
tube guy I'm a flatable tube guy to the
point where look I'm inflatable too guy
look look I'm a flatable tube guy to the
point where I'm like I know kids are
always like hey look look at this look
at me do this look at this look at this
and I'm like
is my son just gonna like when does it
stop
like I understand wanting to to like
sometimes I walk you know it's like you
know what I guess it's like it's like
when you're an adult and you go and see
like a Liam Neeson movie and you walk
out of the movie theater and you're like
wow that was a cool movie I know it's
fake but at this point after seeing that
movie nobody better test me
right
I understand that you know
that's fake and all this and and like
this is movie Magic because I'm 43 but I
just watched Taken and at this point
somebody better not take take test me at
this point somebody better not test me
right the government take my daughter if
I had a daughter if I would get her back
at this point because it's in Taken
but um
I guess that's what it's like for kids
when you just see the grain green
inflatable tube guy and then you go ah
dude this is my taken
uh because now he's just flipping around
doing the thing and so much we're going
to go see Grandma and Grandpa and he was
just
you'd be like Cal and you'd say no I'm
inflatable tube guy
like just okay but it's like when does
it stop I don't know I'm like I'm you
know I
I've been a dad for three and a half
years so it's like now is the time where
the imagination is just like really
like coming into like its own and he's
just like she's something like that and
he's just like I can be that guy like as
a kid when you like my butt my kid my my
uh I showed him PeeWee Herman you know
rest in peace because I thought I was
like you know what Calvin loved Pee-wee
Herman so I showed him PB Herman and he
was watching me with her and PeeWee
Herman was doing his dance and one of
the things and I look over to Calvin and
and Calvin is watching the show and he
says he is so funny
and I was like okay so he loves purring
but once that inflatable tube guy
happened boom no more Pee-wee Herman now
he's like what is it peepee pee pee I'm
like no it's Peewee and
so he now watch it uh could care less
could not care less about Peewee and is
he wacky flavor two guy but it's kind of
like the thing because I was telling
that you know Uncle Matt when he was
younger he was Pee-wee Herman for
Halloween and Kevin was like really and
I remember when Uncle Matt was people
remember Halloween he was four I was
seven or eight
and he was going to be PeeWee Herman
and he had a mask right which is a
really a [__] ass
way to go honestly if you're doing
Halloween as a kid or an adult
but a kid mostly if you do a costume
where you put a mask on
you're a lazy [__] you know
get the makeup
have Mom do the makeup have dad you know
what I mean hire someone
maybe that sex is to say that the dad
would Dad could do it too
right
mom doesn't have to do a mom hire
someone whatever it is whoever this is a
breadwinner it's most likely the dad dad
hire someone okay
um
and
so my brother was Peewee and he was
Peewee you don't when you're a kid as an
as a a Halloween costume I was The
Punisher one year and the thing was you
wouldn't have wanted to test me back
then now yeah
I was 11.
but you don't want to test me at that
point right yeah I had a gun that wasn't
a real gun that had an orange tip that
didn't shoot bullets but when
I get it it's not that dangerous but
you don't want to test me at that point
right because I was The Punisher do you
understand
I was robbing too why was I not Batman
because I wanted to do that I wanted to
be the kind of under like everyone's
Batman
so I wanted to be I wanted to be Robin
and my mom made the Robin costume kinda
and yeah in retrospect Robin is the
[__] ass one but they're both wearing
tights right so it's like up until
recently there they used to wear tights
in the 80s the superheroes were all tied
it up now they're just it's armor and
[__] you know
now it's badass but back then was
totally not badass it was tight City
nobody wanted to play Superman so that's
what Christopher reads today he wasn't
even a superhero he wasn't even a
superstar they were just like no one
will do it Warren Beatty said no because
you put on the outfit
Christopher Ruiz is like uh I'll do it
boom
then they did four of them
but yeah my son's the green inflatable
tube guy and uh and I did a [__]
killer leg day so things are looking up
for both of us dude I mean I did a
[__] killer leg day and I know that
people in my
you know they're like oh Chrisley I
don't want to talk don't talk about
working out again well here it comes
dude skip [__] a minute because dude
your boy is
your boy's hips have been through so
much
and they and you can tell because
they're absolutely crying I mean above
the kneecap I got that teardrop that is
oh just so ridiculously juicy
right
I got people coming up to me now they
know I I strictly do legs they go like
this hey work some arms I go like this
no Johnny uh from uh that book of power
show or whatever he saw me at the gym
and he was like Hey work out some arms
and I go like this strictly legs all day
he says let's work out together I go
sure you do legs though
dude my trunk is gonna be so crazy
there's gonna be [__] Pirates Booty
in it
anyway dude I talk about working out a
lot that was that but I had a crazy leg
day I'm so sore dude
and uh the thing about working out your
bottom half is your top half get
shredded too Whoopsie Daisy right but
you work out your top half your bottom
half doesn't get shredded so it's like
Sasha palacey today at arawan and he
goes like this what's going on and I'm
like dude I'm getting beefed up and he
says how do I do that I said you gotta
go to the war we gotta go to gym every
day and he's like damn and I go hey dude
what do you want from me
he went to everyone to get those two
little [__] ass
[__] things that they trick us into
getting to make it seem like an immunity
boost you know and him holding those
things he looked like a [__] giant
dude he just can't walk into everyone
with two little [__] ass bottles
love that guy
um
yeah so
so that's that's so that's kind of
what's been going on with me my son's
the wacky inflatable tube guy and then
also I had a killer leg day
um
sup with
uh [__] Jamie Foxx huh you did they
just wanna they don't give a [__] what
he meant right they just wanted to be
like oh you see he he's it's because of
him that the Holocaust happened right
why can't dude
this is the you know what I wish it was
when he said when when when Jamie Foxx
so here's what happened Jimmy fox says
if they kill Jesus what do you think
they'll do to you fake friends now
everybody who isn't super sensitive
would be like oh yeah he's talking about
untrustworthy people I didn't even think
of the thing but then people really said
to people were like wait he's talking
about the Jews because people think the
Jews killed Jesus and all that [__] even
though Jesus isn't real and uh kidding
kidding he might be I have no idea dude
I'm not the end-all be-all of what
happened in like the 1800s or whenever
it was
and so
um I'm kidding dude there's so many
people named Jesus
and in Mexico they're Jesus so
um
anyway
he's so he made a post about fake
friends which is something Jamie Foxx
would absolutely do
okay
that's what people do when they're Jamie
Foxx
all right they make posts about fake
friends especially after what went down
with him like you know he's got people
thought he had Ms and [__]
and now he makes supports about fake
friends so people go oh dude he's
talking about Jews
you know some Jews are saying it some
other people who aren't you you don't
say that about Jews during Times Like
These with so much anti-semitic stuff
going on and Jimmy fact Fox is all hey
hey what I didn't mean that and that
should be the end of that but people say
doesn't matter you did it and this is
how we took it and yes you did mean it
and now with anti-Semitism running
rampant you need to be held accountable
for it cut ties with Jamie Foxx and it's
all okay but he didn't mean it
plus now black people are saying it's
Black Culture to say they they meaning
the people that keep us down that want
to oppress us or whatever or backstab us
or whatever the hell it is my thing is I
wish it was DJ Khaled
I wish it was DJ Khaled and not Jimmy
Fox that did this because he's been
saying they don't want us to succeed
they don't want us so we they don't want
us to get shrimp so we get some shrimp
and Jamie and and for me like they the
ones that killed Jesus and for people to
be like that's anti-semitic be like you
couldn't do it the DJ Khaled you know
and Jamie Foxx put out an apology dude
you got it they probably pressured it
into him the producers of we clone
Tyrone pressured him into it dude
the producer of let's meet Shazam or
whatever his [__] jerky game show is
pretty they [__] dude
beat Shazam right let's meet Shazam wow
an 80s sitcom
beat Shazam that's what it's called his
his game show
man
you better call
Tyrone call him
but you can't use my phone so dick
what's her name
Erykah Badu dude and people are just
like she's [__] absolutely
unbelievable the Artistic integrity and
then she's all just like you better call
Tyrone so basic call him but you can't
use my phone now basically and then rude
to be honest
[__] you that's my phone hands up take
your dirty mitts off my phone it's mines
but yeah dude
Jamie Fox isn't
anti-semitic and that's very obvious
I'm sick and tired of this [__]
but you know that's where we're at and
it's fine and it's fine and it's it's
fine okay
um
I don't know man
apologizing because I don't say this a
lot but apologizing at this point it's
[__] weak sauce dude
I hate that so much
um
how about they got lizzo dude though
lizzo [__] is
unbelievable oh dude lizzo called you
fat oh yeah that
shouldn't bother you
just point your eyes in the direction
where the words coming from
you'll feel fine about it
I mean for [__] sake that's like
calling Steve Buscemi ugly hey just
point your eyes in the direction that
the words are coming from you'll be all
right
who said that oh you you think I'm oh
I'm fine hey also
dude and you know did
dude
she pressured me into she pressed she
that's the thing she pressured me into
touching a banana that's coming out of
another lady's vagina hey
I'm I'm good now that you should I'm
good nah but you should hey I'm out of
here
oh yeah well you're fat
oh you're gonna hear from my lawyers
dude here's what you say when lizzo says
you're fat you go like this
you're fat
also here's the thing they were in a
party environment and they put a banana
in the ladies vagina or whatever which I
don't condone no fruit goes anywhere
except in the mouth I feel like right
unless honestly if you think you can get
a watermelon up your anus then okay
straight up I want to see it
I want to see it go down
just put it in your angels then burp up
the seeds
eight a million dollars and [__] at four
million quarters who's the rapper that
said that like it's hard but also why
um
eight a million dollars and [__] it for
a million quarters
he's just said [__] the bank really
are you did you type it in
who is it you know okay anyway uh they
were having a party they stuck some
bananas up some Uchi Wally and they say
Hey you know touch a banana hey hey you
should do it no okay oh hey
ah and then you know it turned into
what's up we're all fat [__] you fat
huh [__] and she's like yeah okay you
know it's just like you made me touch
the banana in the oochi Wally and then
you're talking about my weight and
you're you're not it's not like you've
seen a treadmill very you know recently
so it's like oh
and then some ambulance Chasers came
through and was like hold on they did
what and you worked for her so hold on
that's workplace harassment and it's
like dude come on we're all gonna be
dead in 20 years anyway there's aliens
think about how in 2000 if alien if the
if the if Congress was like yo there's
aliens we would have stayed indoors for
seven years and now people are like uh
hey there's aliens and then someone else
is like yeah but lizzo called me fat
and and Jamie Foxx hates Jews
and you go
hmm good point
it is so crazy dude so guess what dude
Nama lizzo fan
I [__] love lizzo dude don't know one
of her songs what's the one that goes
I'm that [__] I'm 100 that [__]
I stick a banana in your Uchi Wally
um so yeah dude it's like they're really
coming for the black people man now it's
like lizzo and Jamie Foxx this is the
thing about the woke they just they
don't they don't give up they don't give
this is why it doesn't pay to be woke
lizzo was woke as [__] with all the
what's her thing called
big girls or whatever with no eye
big girls did she has a show called big
girls and people are like oh you know
it's great she's given you know plus
size women which is like you know
I mean
chances of dancing or what I don't know
what they do they dance
it's just too it's all good
it's too much but it's all good but it's
too much but it's all good right but the
aliens are good we're gonna be dead what
20 years is good you give us 20 years
I'm just like you give us 20 year I
don't think so
I don't know about uh
but whatever it is what it is
um
and I feel like
what was the [__] thing see that's
the thing is too much sensationalism
because of uh how uh
Elon Musk and what's his name's gonna
maybe fight Zuckerberg put a thing out
on threads where he was like I like how
they just like they don't respond to
each other on each other's platform
on they like he'll Zuckerberg was a
screenshot and then put it on threads
he's like nah this one
um
and he put it
uh Elon Musk said I'm training for the
fight
I don't have time to work out
um but I'm gonna that's why I brought my
weights with the to the gym or to the to
my workplace
okay fine but then also
um and then Zuckerberg was like I I
suggested August 26th
um
but I haven't heard from him so I'm not
holding my breath Zuckerberg is in it
Zuckerberg's gonna win this thing
and I hope when he submits him he goes
Facebook
boom smashes his head
this one's for Threads oh and this one's
for Facebook oh and this one's for meta
ah
um
so I don't think that's gonna I don't
know if that fight's gonna happen I
think if it was up to honestly
Zuckerberg it would happen but I think
that Elon Musk it's like just be the
Bruce Wayne that you are don't lose this
fight right
both guys I guess stand to gain
something from this even if they do lose
but it's like
I feel like elon's dick is too big to do
this
because what if people realize it's
shorter
um speaking of fights though that
[__] Jake Paul Nate Diaz fight for
some reason my wife is like all about
these fights I didn't even I I knew it
was common because of social media and
[__] and I followed Jake and Logan but
like
uh my wife was just like
let's go downstairs and watch the fight
and I was watching Pee-wee Herman with
Calvin and I was like uh I don't I want
to watch this with him you know and she
was like okay I'm gonna go down and
watch it and I was like okay so she did
it we watched an episode of Peter Herman
the Apple Calvin the bad and I went down
another uh
um
we usually to be honest we usually both
put him to bed if we're home if I'm home
I should say and then we there if I do
one night she'll do another night
um but
like she did last night it's very even I
hate when I'm out of town though and I
don't get to do it
I FaceTime a lot whatever I digress so
um I went down the thing and and she was
like man Jake Paul has been really like
punching him a lot in the beginning I
was like oh yeah Diaz is crazy though
like he has crazy stamina but he isn't a
boxer so whatever and um and the last
round it was like getting heavy and
[__] Christians nowhere to be seen
him like where the [__] are you going
she's like I can't watch it I'm like
dude I didn't even want to watch this
[__] and now I'm watching you're not not
that I didn't want to watch it it was
fun to watch it but uh Nate Diaz was uh
uh I don't know
man if that was I know they say they
want to do MMA which is crazy because
that's the whole thing the whole thing
about what Nick Dia Nate Diaz says was
about how like yeah he may be in boxing
but it doesn't mean he can fight
which is so true dude
that's not fighting it really isn't the
more and more I watch Boxing that's not
fight that's not fighting
it's boxing it's a sport it's a complete
Sport and UFC is absolutely fighting
what's the [__] uh what Nick Diaz
Diaz
interview this is what I wanted to watch
that Nick they got Nick Diaz Nick Diaz's
Brother on
um
no Nick Diaz
that was pretty wild
come on come on
I I can't find the video guys sorry I
can't find the video but he was
absolutely on [__] zooted dude he was
just zooted he was like ah I I wanna
I'll fight Logan the only thing that
makes sense I fight Logan and Nate Diaz
is a huge star Nick Diaz is a star in
the UFC Community but Nate Diaz
transcends the uh the thing so I don't
know if I don't know if they're gonna
get that fight going on it's all about
entertainment anyway but whatever it's
not boxing It's Entertainment right it's
gonna agree on that but maybe I mean I
I'm not to take anything away from Jake
Paul I think Jake Paul has been really
put in the work and he looks like a good
boxer although that's me coming from
from become a comedian from become a
comedian from a comedian I mean you know
Foghorn Leghorn um
so that's what's up I think it's great
that uh Gucci Mane is coming out with a
[__] show um an album called
woppenheimer you know what the [__] is
[__] anyway is that a thing that that
rappers do
Oppenheimer like
what is this
Oppenheimer um
Gucci Mane on
wappenheimer out now oh it's out now
dude
hell yeah dude
shouldn't it be
guapenheimer because that means like
money dude
hmm
I'm uh not and I'm not really good at
hip-hopping though so here we go dude
this is the video I saw and this is
insane dude
a demon came with his penis uh uh gonna
start it over Dude
gonna start it over demon came with his
penis
so descriptive here we go
a demon came with his penis and put it
in my mouth
dude you know
I mean it sounds like something a demon
would do that's that's true and and then
he tried he came again and he slept with
me last week
that just keeps sleeping around you know
it was a demon and then he came again
and since then my private part has been
itching Did It Roar as herpes dude did
it Rose chlamydia did it Rose gonorrhea
dude wasn't a demon was Derek
um
okay hit her in the head wow so assault
dude I know how to make this assault
better Mara salt who are you
who are you
this sucks dude honestly people are so
it's so fake and you can tell it's fake
and even she is like when she's going in
her head she's like I hope this is real
because something needs to work
a demon came inside that might came in a
demon came in with his penis
now he's spraying her oochi Wally
through her Jess
uh some white stuff came out
dude the dog the dog the meme of the dog
like this
some white stuff came out when I went to
the bathroom 15 minutes later he got
gonorrhea dude you got gonorrhea from
Derek
wasn't a demon dude was Derek
after I spray with the water after I
spray with the water dude absolutely
Bonkers insane Rob Hayes sent me that
shout out to Rob hay on the uh on the
patreon but yeah dude a demon that's I
don't know man
some women would brag about that dude
you know I got babadook in the bed you
know I got babadook don't you don't you
know I got babadook so
my back hurts that's great dude that's
great how my back hurts dude
all right took a little peepee break
man this Megan
Rapinoe
rupino not rapino
rapino sounds right because it's uh
sounds Italian Megan hello I am
dude she is David Spade
um he so she lost so she makes a big
thing about super being uh super woke
and [__] she's got teal hair and um bro
she she didn't make her penalty kick
dude leave her alone first of all you
know but that's the thing about
people are just like you know she misses
a penalty kick and now everyone's like
it doesn't even go from like oh dude you
ruined it they just go Die slow [__]
you know and that's crazy so it's like
uh leave her alone but that's what
happens when you [__] [__] [__] and
you're really annoying dude and then
that happens you know
I don't know and then Trump is just on
immediately you know he's immediately on
one because she said she would not go to
the thing she would not go to the White
House if she was invited right or there
was an open invitation or something
um who once refused to visit the Trump
White House yeah okay and um
so she did this she missed the paint the
the field the field goal or whatever
they lost to Sweden by the way which is
that are they even good
um I don't feel like Sweden Swedish
people can play soccer well you know
because they don't have to because their
life is so dope
the [__] Swedish people is Awesome by
the way dude
are are there just like white people in
Sweden or what it's like pretty white
and blonde right
I mean that's what it's known as
look I'm tired of hearing that honestly
America is America is racist because
we're letting everybody in
that's why it's hard to be with people
anyway any difference dude you see a
short white dude
and he's in the way you're like hey
short [__] move you know what I mean
it's all about what they look like hey
hey a big guy FF [__] hey two steps to
the side can you do that
without having a [__] Cardiac Arrest
that's what happens you look at the
differences so if it's a black guy or an
Asian all of a sudden you do [__] that's
going to lead to stop Asian hate but my
point is America's not even really the
racist country dude we're letting
everybody in the racist countries are
the [__] like Sweden dude
they're the people that are just White
bring them out
invite the black people invite the
Asians but you won't though right you
know how hard it is to get a [__] uh
uh what do you call it a um
uh uh uh Visa over there
for black or Asian dude because they're
like no no we actually don't want them
we we feel good for them and we want
them to be happy
but we are all full at this point we
Have No Vacancy
yeah
treat us like La Quinta Inn okay we
cannot have this here
we are a Radisson basically you don't
have a very
dude so I'm tired of hearing the [__]
America's built on racism well at a
minute at least
we're awesome dude yeah you know there
are race Wars but still we're letting
them in
let's figure it out
so they lost to Sweden which is I can't
imagine you're good at soccer dude
countries that are good at soccer are
are poor as [__] countries that only
have soccer they got like [__]
Christmas is like a winter wonderland in
Sweden they have money you know
but you you know Colombia and you know
Cuba and like [__]
the one with the e
and then Venezuela those places have to
be good because they're like you know
the only thing I had when I was young
was this bowl
and now I am able to live in the life of
luxury right
all I have in this world
is my ball
[Laughter]
I haven't all I haven't like the [__]
so uh Donald Trump was just like he goes
like this onto on X I guess it's called
now God that's so [__] annoying
the loss was fully emblematic of what is
happening to our once great nation under
crooked Joe Biden you know
he wrote on a social media platform oh
his social media platform does he have
one now or did he use Twitter that's a
Twitter many
oh this is truth social is that so they
so he didn't use Twitter anymore or he
does he does not oh wow
oh wow okay he's unblocked but still
doesn't use it many of our players were
openly hostile to America no other
country behaved in such a manner or even
close I love that so Trump to be like or
even close
he added woke equals failure
Nice Shot Megan the USA is going to hell
uh
Maga dude going to hell imagine if you
missed the penalty kick and and the
devil was just like that's enough
and they just bring USA down with them
the blue haired woke woman lost well
actually is she woman I don't know how
she identifies but
she missed the penalty kick
so uh yeah
I'm annoying one fire told me he was
rapping now and not rapino because
that's ridiculous but and so I said it
rapping oh but I know it's rapino so
it's all good
yeah I know it's okay
um
everything's crazy but it's okay dude
honestly I'm gonna be totally true
because Wayne Brady came out as
pansexual so that's cool I love Wayne
Brady dude
and he's pansexual now a lot of people
are confused what pansexual means what
pansexual means is you're not attracted
to gender you're just attracted to a
person and if you love them you'll
[__] blast them right you'll blast
them so it doesn't matter
a lot of people like well that's bi
because you just you'll blast whoever
and he's like no pansexuals were like no
it doesn't matter if they're male or
female or anywhere in between if I love
them I love them and that's when I'll do
the Blasted
that's when I'll absolutely cream inside
of them right it doesn't matter what
they are
okay but it's kind of bi in a way but
it's pan all right well you call
Tomatoes Tomatoes whatever you want if
I'm in love with them I'm doing blasting
inside that's what I'm doing okay male
or female secondary love him blasting
right so uh Wayne Brady came out as
pansexual and uh you know but he's been
married forever so he's never really
blasted inside anyone except his wife
which is cool so can you really say yeah
you can be totally you can be gay if you
didn't blast in dudes right
it's all up in here isn't it
I want to blast dudes but I don't blast
dudes I'm gay I blast dudes but I didn't
wanna I'm not gay not crazy but if
you're still doing gay stuff right
you're doing gay activities
right so while you're doing good
activities if you're not gay so maybe
there's some stuff in there that maybe
leads to points to the gayness which is
fine and I'm not saying Wayne Brady I'm
just saying someone who's gay
um so congrats to Wayne Brady for coming
out as pansexual you know I'm just gonna
I'm My Own sexual my own sexual that's
what I am I'm My Own sexual and that's
what I do and what is it it's pretty
much heterosexual oh okay
um
cool sounds good
but it's my thing so it's my own sexual
um
mind sexual Idaho
people told me that movie's good never
watched it never wanted to didn't care
it won't won't watch it dude when that
came out everyone was all talking about
it that was the first time ever was like
this did everyone talk about this too
much I'm not going to see it dude he's
himself
um
that's what that chick that was in some
stuff and then never in any other things
he probably just had a family and [__]
she's a huge Trump supporter you know
dude it's so uh
I'll tell you what dude
man my younger self just learned I
learned that Natalie Portman's single
now my younger self goes like this damn
dude Natalie Portman she's crushed
shitty dude love Natalie Portman and she
uh is getting a divorce which sucks dude
I hate when people break up really hate
it
and they're breaking up and I think it's
rumored to be that the husband cheated
and then it's like oh okay well that's
you know you know it sucks and then you
learn he's French and you go like this
well it's not cheating if he's French
you know I mean like French Dudes you
gotta know that's in their blood right
they say they don't even they don't even
count it as cheating because there's
doesn't have a love involved but of
course you know did you [__] another
woman
what but what about our vows and that it
does not have anything to do with this
that is uh something else
but did you cheat no no why not because
I only love you
but why did you stick your dick in a
woman it was plenty it wasn't just one
but of course but
French Jews just do it French French
Dudes
Chi at brunch
you know
like
they can't it's unfair to tell a French
dude yo you know you can't he would they
would literally
shame you on Twitter until you committed
suicide
um but yeah Natalie Portman is single
and the French guy did the French [__]
you know
honestly getting mad at a french guy for
cheating is like getting mad at a a
[__] for being short or not being able
to reach the peas
um I guess you can't say [__] but it's
okay it's fine uh Benjamin millipede
oh yeah an affair that's what that's
what US says us isn't [__] Reports dog
[__] stuff so who knows
uh
uh it's crazy that Natalie Portman is
42.
wow
rumor swirled that millipede was having
an affair with Camille
Etienne
a climate activist well I'll tell you
something right now do not have an
affair with a climate activist that
shit's gonna just go up in flames
wow
and I'll tell you what they'll never
blame Camille atene the climate activist
let's see who she is
Camille etanae
25 year old climate activist huh
imagine being a climate activist
imagine being a for real climate
activist that's what you're known as
That's crazy dude
people using hairspray like no no hey
hey those on
um
oh dude everyone's talking about this
[__] fight that happened with the uh
boat and the um
uh
and the uh were the boats trying to Dock
and the and the white guys are not
moving the boat
you see this the white guys are not
moving the boat and the black guy's like
hey you gotta move the boat we got a
huge [__] it was like a huge uh what
do you call them like
ship not ship but like a big thing and
he's like I'm supposed to be parking
here or whatever they do docking here
and the white guys are like nah
and then the black guy is and the white
the black guy and the white guy that
come up to each other and the white guy
swings up on him
and and then the black guy starts
fighting back and then and then it's all
I have heard about for the past two days
and then I'm like all right I'll watch
it I watch it it's not that [__] big
of a deal dude it's like what white guys
were on a boat and then black guys were
on the other boat and then the black
guys came to defend the other black guy
and people are making it like it's
racing it probably it's probably a
little I don't know if it is this one
goes back to what I was saying
dude people just don't like differences
if you're fighting a guy who looks
different in your head you're like [__]
this [__] whatever he is
ah come on you fat [__] you know
so all of a sudden I'm fighting a black
guy I'm racist
that's how it's going in my head
all of a sudden I'm doing Asian I'm
fighting an Asian guy I'm like all right
that's cool
but it's too bad we're not in a driving
competition you know I would [__]
kill it and and in my head I'm doing
that right I'm not saying it out loud in
the fight because that would be racist
but in my head I'm practically in a
retirement community in [__] West
Palm Beach that's how racist I am do you
know
because like I'm not
I don't care if you're what that's how
unracist I am I don't care what color
creed religion [__] or not you are
whatever you are I'm gonna be mad at
that and use that that I that's why I
hate you did it say what I'm saying it's
backward logic in a way but it's not in
a way
because I will hate you equally
as I will for somebody in a different
minority or shortness or fatness if I'm
fighting you and that's the reason why
my hate is gonna kick driving the Mach
11 right because you know ah yeah too
bad you didn't put down some of the
pizzas you might have been a [__] a
little bit better with it pop right I
don't hate fat people but right now I do
right
and that's across the board for everyone
dude and if you act like it's not that
it dude I'm in line someone cuts in and
it's a [__] short guy
right
where's your dad buddy that's me
because you cut in line and I'm using
what I see that's the difference between
us
right
a bald guy gets in line hey bud this
ain't the line for [__] toupees
right because I look at what the
difference is between us
[Laughter]
so now a black guy comes or now an Asian
guy comes in oh [__] he's racist but
really that's just the difference
between us
is that I can't be blindfolded with
dental floss and it's
so stupid stupid dude I'm a [__]
[__]
I don't you know
because guess what if you don't say
anything silence is violence too
so
I'm right here in line and you cut in
front of me and whatever you are that's
who I hate now
so I saw that [__] boat thing and it
was just like it was okay man but the
commentary from the the the the the the
people who filmed it the black people
the people who filmed it that happened
to be black the commentary was just way
way better you know I mean way better uh
there's a black lady who did it you know
what I'm actually gonna pull it up I'm
gonna pull it up
um
what's the [__] link here because I
gotta pull this up here
yeah I got I got I know I got I got the
link actually Riverboat brawl in
Montgomery
um I got it right here
ah let's send it out let's send it out
is that here okay here we go here we go
did this lady who happens to be black
was killed in the commentary honestly
ESPN should hire being dead serious
um oh my God Sandra Bullock's partner
died
that's horrible
all right here it is
the fighting continued this was it dude
her [__]
commentary I swear to God she's the
Chris Berman of [__] bud fights
Gonzalez
come on dude computer doesn't work yes
dude
here we go
loading ad great
uh
come on guys stick with me guys let's
just wait together it's not fair I have
to do the waiting and now there's an ad
so it's not fair I have to do the
waiting so you do the waiting with me so
here we go but this is it uh it says
soon though other black people jump to
the dude I love how the guy threw his
hat up and then all the other black
people came somebody said it was like
the bat signal for for black dudes which
is hilarious dude
here we go
we're trying to get on the supercycle
the Marriott trying to come through and
the man would sit in the mood a boat
because the Marriott couldn't die so the
folks could get off and everybody was
super cycle we've been waiting
I don't remember to jump down
the Chris Brown in the boat fights
here we go
that's awesome they're ready to move
something magic Chris Bermuda they're
ready to move something
oh wow not even a part of it a story
above
oh
you know woo girls are the worst
wow beat they ass
what you get hell yeah dude I swear to
God
tear their ass up wow sex um
if they
if if
someone fell in the water
y'all were wrong dude
Elvis Elvis dude how amazing is it that
uh
if honestly ESPN harder that would be
the [__] dude
oh [__] he knocked it out the park oh
it's gone uh-huh I swear to God ESPN
would [__]
it would you know it would you know it
would so but they won't [__]
[__]
I guess you don't really believe black
lives matter pussy's ass ESPN guys
um
let's see this baseball fight here
Jose Ramirez
rocking Tim Anderson
safe
oh [__]
no like this is hockey
oh we [__] him up oh we didn't even
look
[__] even look that was a bad fight
let's watch it again
that was a bad fight but he got lucky
here we go
well why are they mad I gotta know dude
I don't care
Ramirez didn't even look
[Music]
they didn't even look he'd even look
dude that's unbelievable he didn't even
look
he was throwing Haymakers and connected
that's not fair it doesn't count doesn't
count redo
redo dude they fought what is this they
felt like they were hockey players bro
let me tell you something have you ever
met a hockey player
have you ever met a [__] hockey
player
dude they are so tough
it's unbelievable
I can't even believe
when you shake their hands it's like
shaking a tree
and they've gotten so many fights dude
and their balance is [__] amazing you
know
that's why they're so good at fighting
I see guys at the gym on that bosu ball
you know doing like one
one-handed [__]
deadlifts or single leg deadlifts and
I'm just like yeah you're working on
your balance you could probably fight
good
I need to get on that [__] I need to
start doing them
deadlifts with one leg but it hurts my
hips kinda
wow this is really adult this is really
devolved honestly
um
from the boat fights to that but I just
feel like
uh hockey players are so dope and
they're cool and they're also sexy and
that bothers me
because hockey players
are [__] they work out all the time
and they're so good with their
legs and I'm so jealous of their legs
and they can fight on Ice which is crazy
if you think about it
and my wife probably likes them and
even when they get older
is it good to date an athlete and marry
an athlete
because most of let's just take it at
face value
athletes are really good at what they do
and their top
they're good for like I guess breeding
and [__] like you know Mark McGuire his
kid will probably be good at [__]
running
especially with that ass that McGuire's
got a [__]
dump truck right
I dress it up real nice I wouldn't do
anything to it I just dress it up real
nice and take pictures of it
but um
yeah McGuire's got like a dump truck
which is great but then it's like
most ball players are [__] idiots you
know and I don't mean ball players only
I mean mostly athletes are just idiots
you know
generally
uh but it doesn't mean that they're all
idiots some of them are very smart
okay but the focus is on
chasing a ball so you don't really get
smarter doing that unless you're also
reading or having great in-depth
conversations which you're not because
you're hanging out mostly with other
guys who are chasing a ball
all right or catching a ball you know so
it's like
you know these chicks and stuff they
like are like yeah athletes are hot and
they are hot and they might you know
blast you into Oblivion but
you better just get Knocked Up and then
steal their money right because
for the long run
I'm not sure you want to be with an
athlete now that's not saying you want
to be with a [__] right you're not
interested in Kirk Behavior you're not
interested in the like a guy that would
be in a [__] T-Mobile commercial do
you know what I'm talking about you're
not interested in a guy that would be
really an adding commercial honestly
because the people who are in
commercials are straight up mister keeps
it dry you know what I mean like they're
just ridiculous they look ridiculous
dude
guys in commercial are just [__] they
should all be billed as Mr keeps it dry
because that's just they're just so
[__] you know and like they're in like
an Argyle Sweater and like some black
wire rim glasses and [__] and they're
like can I help you can I help you with
your mobile plan and you're just like
dude
what it up man
I can't why because I'm Phil keeps it
dry you know what I'm talking about so
it's like you want the guy in between
right
you want the guy in between you don't
want a rock star because they do a lot
of drugs I'm just saying
you don't want a banker because they do
hella Coke right they can't stop doing
coke
the amount of time a banker the amount
of times a [__] Banker or a broker
goes like this what's up and you see
[__] white cake under their nose is
it's honestly 35 of the time when a
banker says what's up that they have
white cake under their nose
so it's like
who do you go for
right
and I think that deep down women do
really respect loyalty and that's the
number one thing they want Even though
bags and [__] are so dope and shoes but
a woman really wants loyalty right so
it's like who's loyal not dumb won't
spend hella money on Bolivian marching
powder
and
will be a good family man
but needs to make some money
so it's like
you can't go school teacher because they
make [__] chips
they make nothing who's that leave you
got to get like a guy who owns a
business that's what you got to have you
business but not a business that's too
successful like if you date the CEO of
Kaiser Permanente that guy's got crazy
demons he won't stop building you know
you got to get a guy who is like the CEO
of
a sandwich place that has like three
places
locally you know
and he's got like we make a lot of money
but there's also a lot we've got to pay
a lot of guys you know so it's like I'm
always trying to figure it out that
guy's the best guy
all right
I'm glad I figured it out for you I'm
the dating Guru I'm like I'm a hitch
that stupid [__] movie with Will
Smith
um anyway dude I'm glad to be there for
you because I'm hitch
but yeah dude
it's crazy you want something crazy but
you also don't want the crazy thing you
know God really [__] us on that
God really [__] us on that didn't they
because like we we want stability but we
also
our midbrains are activated when you see
a [__] red Lamborghini not red that's
not my thing but if the shit's the color
of throw up holy [__] I need that you
know
if I see a Lamborghini the color of
throw up I'm basically a Komodo dragon
like I need to [__] get in that car
my midbrain activated like I'm one of
the [__] Avengers like I'm in fight
mode I need to get in that [__] car
right
but also I know that that's I can't put
two [__] car seats in the back of
that they don't even have two seats in
the back so I'm like all of a sudden the
lambo the color throw up that's out the
door but I still want it but it's like
okay I'm not gonna be Mr keeps the drive
with a [__] minivan so I get the Audi
rsq8 I guess but then it's like
can we tint the windows and my wife's
like I can't see out the windows if we
did it and I'm like what if we do a
lower grade than we did with the [__]
bloody guts Mercedes and she's like
I don't really want to so I'm like all
right
life's all about balance my babies I
guess that's what it is and you know you
won't want to go to minivan but you
don't want to go to
activate the midbrain too heavy because
then it's like you might as well be a
[__]
Komodo dragon with poisonous saliva
you know it's not even the poisonous
saliva it's the bacteria in it that gets
all in your cut and then you get a
[__] potato lag and [__] so it's like
okay
either way dude I love you guys and I
really appreciate you go on stop by the
crystalia store and get some merch and
I'll be in Charlotte and Knoxville and
Little Rock Arkansas and Nashville and
Canada so go to chrisley.com to get them
tickets like And subscribe you know we'd
love it if you leave a comment
uh and we'd love it if you [__] make
sure you're subscribed because a lot of
times they've you know the man messes
with us right
they really mess with us and I don't
mean Jews just by just because I said
they right I just mean whoever I mean
people I mean the man that's what I mean
so um I appreciate you and then also uh
subscribe and then uh I'll see you on
the road uh uh also we'd love it if you
sign up on the patreon patreon.com
crystalia get every
um we have like 33 episodes there that
are not available to the public and
that's just six bucks you get those and
you get to chat with us on the Discord
and uh you know
you send us videos we talk about them on
the podcast like Rod hay did today shout
out to Rob hey so I appreciate you guys
thanks guys
[Music]